Transcriber: Majd Mustafa
المدقّق: DAHOU Mohamed
مرحبا
آسف صوتي متعب قليلا.
قررت قبل فترة بسيطة أن أكتب مذكراتي،
ويمكن للشخص
كتابة مذكراته على شكل قصة،
لكن يمكنه أيضا التعمق فيها أكثر،
وسيكتشف أن الكثير من الأشياء التي قام بها،
الكثير من الأمور التي قرر القيام بها،
هي ليست بملك إرادته.
لقد كانت هناك قوة أكبر منه،
جعلته يأتي بما قام به.
أنا ولدت في قرية بير زيت.
هذه عائلتي
ذاك جدي وأبي بالمنتصف
الذي لم يكن متزوجا بعد.
قرر جدي بناء بيت بعيدا عن البلدة
بمنطقة كلها كروم عنب
وأشجار زيتون،
وفيها ينابيع ماء
وفيها برك سباحة وغيرها.
وأنا ولدت في هذا المكان
ونشأت فيه إلى أن بلغت خمس سنوات،
وفي سن الخامسة توفي ابي،
فاضطرت أمي، حيث كنا
ستة إخوة وأخوات،
فاضطرت أمي أن تسجلنا بمدرسة داخلية
ببيت لحم وبيت جالا.
وبالطبع، كنت في كل عطلة صيفية،
ثلاثة أشهر الصيف،
كنت أقضيها بهذه المنطقة،
وهذا الأمر ربى عندي حب للأرض،
ويمكن للمطلع على أعمالي الفنية أن يلاحظ
أنه تقريبا 80% من الأعمال الفنية فيها
هذه الأشياء
في المدرسة،
كان مدير القسم الداخلي ألمانياً،
وكان فنان بالمصادفة.
وبالطبع وقتها،
نحن نتحدث عن أواخر الخمسينيات،
لم يكن هناك تعليم فنون في المدارس،
ولا أحد يهتم بهذا الموضوع،
ولكونه كان فنانا، لاحظ أن هناك عدد
من الطلاب المحبين للفن،
فأسس ناديا فنيا،
وأنا انضممت بالطبع للنادي الفني
واهتم بي كثيرا الأخ.
من ضمن الأمور التي قام بها معي
كانت تشجيعي على المشاركة في مسابقة
نظمتها الأمم المتحدة
للأطفال من جميع أنحاء العالم،
كان شعارها قلوبنا تحنو إلى السلام
أو شيء من هذا القبيل.
وأنا شاركت على مضض في المسابقة
وفزت بها بالصدفة.
وكان هذا الأمر سنة 1961 تقريبا،
فقاموا بإعداد دليل
ووضعوا صورتي على الغلاف
وصورتي وأنا طفل داخل الغلاف.
والأهم من كل ذلك أعطوني مائتي دولار.
المئتي دولار،
ونحن نتكلم عن سنة 1961،
تعني أنه بمقدوري بناء بيت بها.
يعني حالتنا المادية تحسنت مباشرة،
لكن الأهم من ذلك،
أصبح الكل ينظر إلي على أنني فنان.
في المدرسة الأساتذة والطلاب،
وبعد ذلك أصبح أهالي قريتي ينظرون إلي كفنان
وأصبح كل من توفي أبوه أو جده،
يحضر لي صورته الصغيرة لأكبرها له
وأصبحت نوعا ما أجني
مبلغا جيدا من هذا العمل.
وبسبب هذه النظرة الموجهة إلي
من قبل المجتمع والمدرسة والأساتذة والجميع،
يعني أنا عندما أنهيت مرحلة المدرسة
سنة 1965 تقريبا،
لم أفكر كثيرا في ماذا سأدرس بعدها،
يعني أنني مباشرة،
قلت سأدرس الفن.
وهنا يكمن دور...
يعني أصبح لدي...
أنا أعتبره نوعا من غسيل الدماغ،
من قبل الناس المحيطين بي
من عائلتي من القرية من المدرسة.
يعني أنهم من أجبرني على اتخاذ هذا القرار.
هذه أحد الأمور
لكني لست نادما بالطبع من هذا الأمر.
وبعد عودتي من دراسة الفن
بدأت أتعرف على فنانين
مثل نبيل عناني وعصام بدر
فنانين من تلك الفترة.
واكتشفنا وقتها أن هناك تقريبا
18 فنانا يعيشون بالضفة الغربية وقطاع غزة،
فقررنا أن نؤسس اتحادا للفنانين.
كان اتحاد الفنانين هذا...
لا أظن أننا كنا وقتها
على وعي بالأمور السياسية
وبأهمية اتحاد الفنانين،
كنا نرغب في التجمع فقط، ونبحث عن حجة لذلك
كفنانين وأصدقاء، فبحثنا عن حجة
لنجلس مع بعضنا ونتناقش ونتحدث،
فقررنا تنظيم أول معرض سنة 1975،
وذلك بدعم من القوى الوطنية
التي كانت موجودة وقتها.
وقمنا بتنظيم هذا المعرض
بالقدس ورام الله ونابلس
والناصرة وغزة،
كنا نشارك في افتتاحيات تلك المعارض
وبالطبع كان يفتتح تلك المعارض أشخاص
مثل كريم خلف
يعني من القيادات الوطنية في تلك الفترة،
مثل بسام الشكعة بغزة
وتوفيق زياد من الناصرة وغيرهم.
كان يحضرها الكثير من الناس
ومن خلال هذه المعارض والافتتاحيات
كانت تجري نقاشات عميقة،
ونقاشات عنيفة حتى بين الفنان وبين الجمهور.
الجمهور يحاول إجبار الفنان
على رسم أو القيام بالأشياء التي يريدها،
مثل مشاهدة أعمال
حول الأرض المصادرة والسجون والشهداء
وكذا حول الاحتلال والحرية.
يعني يريد جمع
كل آمال الشعب الفلسطيني ومشاكله
ومشاهدتها في العمل الفني.
وبالطبع تأثرنا بذلك مع مرور الوقت،
من خلال مقابلتنا
للقيادات الوطنية بتلك الفترة،
وبدأت الصحافة تكتب أخبارنا،
فبدأنا نأخذ موقفا كوننا سياسيين
أكثر من كوننا فنانين.
يعني أن هذا المناخ العام برمته،
وجهنا نحو السياسة،
لنتعرف بعدها على منظمة التحرير
وبدأنا نسافر إلى بيروت،
وقابلنا أبو عمار أبو جهاد
وجورج حبش والجميع
كانوا يستقبلوننا بالأحضان،
ويطبعون لوحاتنا كأغلفة لفلسطين الثورة
بالمجلات التي ينشرونها.
فكل هذا الجو يعني،
أعطانا انطباع أننا،
لسنا فنانين مهمين وسياسيين فقط،
بل أن الثورة لن تكون من دوننا.
بقينا على هذه الحال تقريبا
إلى غاية 1987 أو 1988،
وكنا نخاف أن نُقْدِمً
على أي تجديد في العمل الفني.
يعني أنه يفترض بنا العمل بهذه الطريقة،
وأنه إذا عملنا بالطريقة الأخرى
بحيث إذا خطر على بال الفنان شيء ما،
والفنان دائما تخطر على باله أشياء غريبة.
الجمهور لن يتقبل ذلك
وأنه عيب ولايجوز وأن هذا ليس دورنا،
فانطلقت شرارة الانتفاضة الأولى
خلال الانتفاضة الأولى،
كان الجميع طبعا يخرج للتظاهر،
نساء ورجال وكبار السن
وأطفال من كل الأعمار،
وأنا أيضا
كنت من الناس الذين خرجوا للتظاهر،
فخرجت سنة 1988 في مظاهرة
وكنت أتوقع أن يتعرف علي الناس.
أنا سليمان منصور يعني،
وأنا الفنان المشهور.
وكنت أتوقع أن الناس سيحملون لوحاتي،
لكن لاحظت أن لا أحد اتنبه من أكون،
ولم ينتبه أحد لا إلى
سليمان منصور أو لأي فنان،
الكل يعمل والكل يقاوم
والكل يرمي حجاره
من دون أن يكون لنا دور كفنانين.
وبالطبع هذا الأمر جعلنا نفكر أكثر،
أننا كنا نعطي أنفسنا حجما أكبر من الواقع.
يعني كنا نعتقد أننا أشخاص مهمين جدًا،
لكن على ما يبدو
الثورة ماضية بطريقها وليست بحاجة إلينا،
يعني دون الحاجة لقيامنا بأي شيء.
هذا الأمر أعطانا الشجاعة،
أعطانا الشجاعة لنجرب،
أشياء جديدة وخاصة وقتها
كانت الفلسفة الأساسية للانتفاضة الأولى
هي مقاطعة المنتجات الإسرائيلية.
فأنا كفنان يعني أريد التحدث عن نفسي،
أنا كفنان قلت لنفسي
لما سأشتري ألوان تقليدية
زيتية ومائية، وأشياء من عند اليهود،
لم تكن هناك محلات تبيعها عندنا نحن،
ومن ثم أرسم ضد اليهود.
يوجد شيء خاطئ في الموضوع.
فبدأت أبحث عن مواد خام محلية من البيئة،
ورجعت لطفولتي،
عندما كنت أساعد جدتي أحيانًا بصناعة...
الشيء الذي أتذكره،
في صناعة بيوت للنحل،
تكون مثل البرميل مغلقة من كل الجهات،
مع مدخل يسمح للنحلة بالدخول والخروج.
والماء واللباس، الشخص يعمل
بالصيف، أطفال يعني.
لكن هذا الموضوع بقي عالقًًا في ذاكرتي،
ومباشرةً فكرت في الطين،
الطين والتبن والقش،
وبدأت أعمل في هذا الموضوع
وأعمل لوحات من الطين.
ذهبت مصادفة لزيارة نبيل عناني،
ووجدت نفس الفكرة لديه،
كان يعمل على الجلد.
وكان يقول أننا لم نعد مهمين حاليا،
وأن دورنا ليس بتلك الأهمية كما كنا نعتقد،
مثلما قلت آنفا،
وهو يعمل الآن في الجلد،
ويضع حناء ورائحة المنزل كلها كريهة،
وذهبنا أيضًا لزيارة الفنان تيسير بركات،
ووجدناه يغلي قشر الرمان ربما أو قشر البصل،
أشياء من هذا النوع، يحاول صنع
الأحبار التي يعمل بها.
الآن، كل هذا،
أقصد كل هذه التجارب التي كنا نقوم بها،
فكرنا بإنشاء مجموعة
اسمها نحو التجريب والإبداع
نحو التجريب والإبداع التي أراها الآن،
هي حلقة الوصل، أهم حلقة وصل
ما بين الفن الذي كنا نمارسه
في الخمسينيات والستينيات
والسبعينيات وحتى الثمانينات،
وما بين الفن المعاصر الذي يجري اليوم.
أي أخرجت الفنانين من اللوحة المربعة
المصنوعة بأدوات ومواد تقليدية،
واليوم تتحرر الفن كثيرًا،
ليس نحن فقط، بل أيضًا الجو العام
تطور الإنترنت،
ولكن كان لنا دور مهمٌ جدًا،
في نقل الفن الفلسطيني،
من الأسلوب التقليدي الذي كنا نعمل به
إلى الأسلوب المعاصر الذي يحصل اليوم.
أريد أن أقول ملاحظة أخيرة فقط،
ليس لها علاقة بموضوعنا
سنة... ربما سنة 1998،
كان الدكتور منذر صلاح
وزيرا للتعليم العالي،
وطلب مني إجراء دراسة
حول التعليم في فلسطين.
فأجريت الدراسة، وجلسنا معا،
وقلت له أنه من الغريب، لماذا لم...
لم يتم إنشاء كلية فنون
قبل اتفاقية أوسلو؟
بعد أوسلو، أصبحت الجامعات
تتشجع على إنشاء كليات فنون.
وهو كان مدير جامعة النجاح سابقًا،
قال لي دعني أخبرك بأمر ما، نحن طوال
هذه الفترة، كنا نحاول أن ننشأ كلية فنون
وبجامعة بيرزيت نفس الشيء،
نحاول أن ننشأ كلية فنون،
وكان يأتينا دائمًا منع.
يقول ليس فقط كلية فنون،
بل كلّيتان كان عليهم نوع من المنع التام.
كلية فنون وكلية زراعة.
لذلك بقليل من الذكاء يمكن الربط بين هاتين
الكليتين والنظرة والفلسفة الصهيونية،
اتجاهنا نحن ولفكرة وجودنا هنا.
نحن شعب ليس لنا الحق بالأرض،
وممنوع أن نعبر عن مشاعرنا
بلغة عالمية يفهمها الناس.
شكراً.
(تصفيق)